bonjour donc je suis médecin à la pitié
salpêtrière et j'ai récemment constatés
après discussion avec certains de mes
amis des attitudes alors à l'encontre
des consignes données par le
gouvernement
souvent par un manque de compréhension
la situation actuelle un manque de
compréhension des modalités de
propagation du virus
il ya donc décidé de faire une vidéo
avec un exemple concret de ce qu'il ne
faut pas faire durant cette période de
confinement donc ici comme vous le voyez
nous avons deux foyers
un foyer 1 et un foyer 2 nous parlerons
en premier uniquement du foyer ce foyer
constitué de trois personnes j'ai décidé
d'y inclure un père une mère et un
enfant mais il pourrait s'agir de trois
collègues de travail ou d'un étudiant de
24 ans avec ses parents ou de ce que
vous voulez donc ici dans mon exemple le
père doit continuer de travailler
oui les livreurs et les soignants bref
il n importe quels métiers nécessitant
de sortir chez lui pour exercer son
métier
donc il sort de chez lui comme vous le
savez je vais rien apprendre à personne
dehors on a le corona virus extrêmement
contagieux qui en vérité n'est pas
dehors qui en vérité et dans les gens
mais qui pour cette vidéo sera dehors
donc ce sera pas étonnant pour vous le
père va être infectés le père va ramener
le virus chez lui dans son foyer dans
son cercle social son enfant et sa
compagne vont donc être infectés à leur
tour bon jusque là c'est facile à
comprendre maintenant l'incubation étant
en moyenne d'une semaine personne ne
saura dans ce foyer until est infecté
durant cette semaine d'incubation voire
même plus que pendant sept semaines
incubation parce que s'ils développent
pas de symptômes par la suite finalement
ils ne sauront même jamais qu'ils ont
été infectées pourtant ils auront quand
même été contagieux pendant cette
période bon le virus étant actuellement
dans le foyer 1
il existe maintenant deux scénarios
possibles primé scénario les mesures de
confinement sont respectées le virus ne
sort pas du foyer 1 les personnes
tombent malades ou resta symptomatique
peu importe
mais le virus ne sort pas de ce cercle
social le confinement aura donc été
efficace la propagation du virus aura
donc été stoppée maintenant le deuxième
scénario qui est celui sur lequel je
veux attirer votre attention et qui est
celui qu'il faut absolument arrêter de
reproduire
c'est que on est au cinquième jour de
confinement il ya une personne dans le
foyer qui en a marre
par exemple en bleu leurs enfants qui
peut aussi être l'étudiant qui en a
marre
la personne âgée qui en a marre bref
cette personne-là en a marre et donc
appel
son collègue de travail qui se situe
dans le foyer de à deux minutes de chez
lui à un pâté de maisons
et donc voilà il s'appelle on n'est pas
malade si tu viens tu croiseras personne
mais au mieux mais un masque et puis
franchement si tu cours dans trente
secondes tu es là ils disent qu'ils vont
voir un verre qui travailleront ensemble
de vive voix parce que c'est mieux qu'au
téléphone bref s'ils vont faire quelque
chose en plus ils en ont marre d'être
confiné ça va juste duré quelques heures
après à la personne du foyer un don qui
est allé chez son ami du foyer 2 va
rentrer chez elle pareil elle va rentrer
chez elle elle habite à deux minutes à
pied en 30 secondes
elle court elle est chez elle elle
croise personne bon donc ils se disent
pas de problème on fait super gaffe on
est bien
c'est vachement safe en contamine
personnes on est vachement responsable
sauf que ici la personne du foyer 1 qui
a infecté sans le savoir comme beaucoup
de français d'ailleurs elle va
transmettre le virus à son ami du foyer
2 peu importe qu'elle croise des gens
sur le trajet en venant ou pas peu
importe elle l'a déjà le virus elle peut
prendre toutes les précautions
nécessaires à elle peut être même dans
le même immeuble
ça change rien elle a le virus cette
personne va voir son ami dans le foyer
de la personne du foyer deux chopes le
virus du coup qu'est ce qui va se passer
cette personne du foyer de va
transmettre le virus à son père à sa
mère à sa soeur pour peu que sa mère
soit par exemple soignantes ou un autre
métier nécessitant de sortir et
travailler elle va infecter de multiples
personnes qui infecte rond eux mêmes de
la même manière leur foyer et cetera
avec un effet boule de neige le père qui
peut travailler à la maison qu'ils
respectent les règles de confinement qui
se dit que du coup ça va aller il
pensait pas que son fils allait être
irresponsable en voyant quelqu'un qui se
situe dans un autre foyer dans un autre
cercle social et va se faire infecter
par son fils il peut présenter aucun
symptôme
il peut aussi présenter quelques
symptômes sans gravité il peut aussi
présenter des symptômes graves comme on
en voit de plus en plus sain et finir à
l'hôpital en réanimation avec
éventuellement des soins mais c'est pas
sûr étant donné qu'un service de réa son
plein à craquer et qui va probablement
bientôt falloir choisir les personnes
qui vont nettoyer ou qui vont pas être
soigné bref la personne
foyer 1 qui pensaient qu'il n'avait
juste à traverser la rue que un pâté de
maison c'est rien qui va croiser
personne en chemin qu'en courant ça mais
30 second débat au final il aura quand
même infecté tout le cercle social du
foyer de lille aura peut-être même
envoyé son père sa mère ou sa soeur en
réanimation alors qu'il n'aura même pas
côtoyer ces différentes personnes il
aura juste vu son ami il aurait quand
même envoyer tout le monde
éventuellement animations et c'est comme
ça que le virus se transmet le message
que je veux passer il est clair c'est
que les cercles sociaux les foyers ne
doivent pas être connecté peu importe
que votre amie habite à côté
peu importe que votre collègue soit dans
le même immeuble peu importe que votre
cousin en face à une belle terrasse au
soleil il ne faut pas mélanger les
différents cercles sociaux pour ne pas
propager le virus dans tous les foyers
peu importe si vous habitez à côté vous
croisez personnellement ça ne change
rien ça n'a aucune importance dans la
propagation du virus
il faut sacrifier temporairement sa vie
sociale car sinon on peut être
responsable de la mort de personne que
l'on n'a même pas côtoyer continuer de
voir vos proches même s'il habite à côté
est totalement irresponsable
ça sert à rien d'applaudir les soignants
à 20h06 à côté vous vous comporter de
cette manière là donc soyez responsable
si vous voulez pas rester confinés
pendant plusieurs mois merci de m'avoir
écouté